you
an arrogant ass about everything that
deals with Amazon you know when when
when when we have problems I say well
it's because you know nobody else has a
you know like has a server farm quite
the size of us this is not truth data
dog I think a dog actually has has an
infrastructure that is that is a larger
more impressive than than shark meat so
basically anything that they ever say I
you know I make sure to listen so Doug
will be talking about how they scale out
their other analytics platform thank you
hello everyone with all apologies to
Darwin I want to start off by giving you
a brief theory on the evolution of a
data project if you've ever worked with
data you've probably done a project that
started out really small maybe you need
to move some data from one application
to another it just needs to happen once
a day so you start off with a Python
script in my experience this is sort of
the gateway drug of data engineering
it's really easy to get started so you
write your Python script you pull a
little data out of the first database
you put it into the second database
maybe some light transformation you put
it in production and it runs really fast
maybe like an hour everything is done so
this is great but then a terrible thing
happens your business is actually
successful and before you know it you're
collecting more and more data and the
Python script it used to run in like an
hour is taking two hours than three
hours and then the Sun is rising and
your Python is still cranking by a show
of hands has anyone ever written this
the script the little Python script it
couldn't write right so in my experience
the next step is you look around and you
say aha we have this database where we
were pulling data out of why don't we
just move our computation over there we
won't have to move any of the data out
it'll be really fast so you rewrite it
as sequel you move it into the live data
base and it's amazing it's it's fast
again but then you hit the next problem
which is that it turns out there was an
application running on that database and
it turns out that it doesn't like you
doing enormous sequence sequential scans
of its data tables it grinds to a halt
people aren't very happy so very quickly
you reach the next step in evolution
which is moving your computation over to
a reporting database
you replicate from the live dB so things
are pretty good usually for a while here
you have a sort of paradise all to
yourself to do enormous reads but then
eventually the data keeps growing more
people find your reporting database when
I do their own things and before you
know it you're buying a bigger database
and then a bigger database and then a
bigger database than that and eventually
you've got the biggest baddest reporting
database that anybody can buy and then
we hit a phase of evolution that there's
really really no fun you've reached the
ceiling of the scalability on a vertical
database and there's really nowhere to
go
fortunately ten years ago this would
have been the state where you have to
stay but now it's not the case in 2016
if you look around you probably have a
Hadoop cluster or a spark cluster that
someone set up or if you don't you can
get a hold of one
if you move your computation over to
spark or over to pig or hive you're
going to be able to scale it
horizontally and things are going to be
good again
this is really nice and in my experience
it not only follows the evolution of a
small data project but also our
evolution of data engineering as we've
gone but what I want to talk about today
is how I think this state of having one
big Hadoop cluster where we do all our
work is not the end of our evolution
rather I think there are some things
that that we've seen that need fixing
with this the first of them is that with
a single cluster your data winds up
locked in it's very very hard to get at
it from all the other places that you'd
like to use data and even more so it
becomes a victim of its own success so
you have this big cluster and everyone
realizes that they can take their slow
Python script and move it onto the
cluster so before you know it you can't
get the time you need to do your work
everyone's waiting around the inhumans
trying to run jobs or automated jobs
trying to run and paradoxically you wind
up also with the state where when
everyone leaves for the night or on the
weekends when nothing's running the
clusters are super underutilized and you
have all this expensive hardware sitting
around so it's a sort of strange thing
where you can't get at the data outside
the cluster the cluster is very very
loaded during the day and you can't get
time on it and then you have expensive
hardware that you're wasting a data dog
we
built a platform that addresses these
concerns and specifically we focused on
the first word there elastic
making it so that it can grow and shrink
as we need and sort of throughout the
day and throughout the week so I'm going
to talk today about the parts of that
platform my hope is that there will be
things that we did and learn that'll be
useful for you all so by way of
introduction I'm Doug I'm director of
engineering at data dawg
work on these data systems and a lot of
other ones if you're not familiar with
data dog we're a monitoring service for
large scale cloud applications so I'm
talking today specifically about our big
data platform and it's mostly focused on
things like Hadoop and spark its main
consumers are data engineers and data
scientists the sort of people that come
to this conference particularly our
internal ones who are trying to do work
on it and the stuff we're doing is
actually rather various we first and
foremost are building features that
shipped directly to our main application
anything that can really emit of higher
latency than sort of a few seconds so
things that can take an hour and it's ok
those things are going on sparking to do
we're also doing a ton of statistical
analysis so things like outlier
detection machine learning a lot of
anomaly detection is going on and then
we use the platform for any sort of
questions we have about how the data is
structured or usage patterns in the data
our main tooling for that at this point
is spark we've switched everything new
that we do over to spark and we're
really loving it we also use Zeppelin
for a lot of the ad-hoc investigation
traditionally we used Pig and we still
have a lot of stuff running it's a real
workhorse for us and then we use Luigi
which was mentioned in the Spotify talk
yesterday as our workflow tool for sort
of coordinating everything I'll talk
about how a lot of these work later on
the talk as a guide to both to talk and
to our platform I'll take it in three
sort of sections the first is is cloud
storage which we find underlies
everything for elasticity and the second
is the the compute that we layer on top
of that which is also highly elastic and
finally a very very essential part of
this is all the tooling that we have
around the edges that makes it possible
to run with such dynamism well start out
though first with with cloud storage
which underlies everything
this part of the talk could probably be
called Amazon s3 a song of love so
before we talk about how we store the
data let's talk a little bit about what
we're actually putting in there so I
mentioned that we're a monitoring
service for a large scale cloud
applications we have over 150 different
integrations from all sorts of things
Web Services databases queueing systems
pretty much anything that people use to
run modern software we're collecting
monitoring data from it and so we
collect several different types of data
out of this but by far the largest and
the most important is time series data
so for a brief primer as to what time
series data is this is a graph of say
the idle the idleness of a system CPU
and so you can see you know it sort of
fluctuates a little bit as time goes by
that with a little dot there is a time
series data point so a little snapshot
of that on the right it's a pretty
simple data type it has a timestamp
tells you when you took the measurement
that's that's just a UNIX epoch up there
it's got a metric which tells you what
you're actually measuring here it's the
system CPU idle it could be the number
of requests to your web server it could
be quite about anything then the value
which is the measurement that you've
actually taken and finally the tags
which give you context for that
measurement so it was on this particular
host that happens to be a Cassandra host
maybe it's in this availability zone
anything you want there so what you'll
notice is that this is a very small data
type there's not much data in each of
these points but we're collecting over a
trillion of these a day at this point
and it's growing very very fast so all
of that data needs a home and for us the
answer is Amazon s3 so I'll tell you
first a little bit about how we actually
get our data into s3 and so this this
architecture folks is specifically on
the Big Data part of what we do there's
also a very extensive real-time
architecture but for this part all the
data is being ingested into Kafka which
is our distributed real-time message
queue and then we have a consumer
actually a set of consumers that are
written in go that are actually
buffering this data to disk into sort of
manageable chunks occasionally sorting
and deduping it and then uploading it to
Amazon s
three in an internal format that we
store this format is optimized for a few
things that we do outside of the Big
Data Platform from there we actually
suck that data back down using Luigi and
a combination of spark and pig jobs and
we rewrite it back as a patchy Parque
there's a talk later on Parque and I
highly recommend it as a format it's
very very nice it's a kilometer data
format that compresses very well and we
use it for as much of our big data as we
can and then finally we're riding over
to a hive Mehta store that's telling us
where to find the data on s3 it's sort
of like a map to to what we're storing
there so that's what we're doing so one
thing you might notice is that there's
no HDFS anywhere on that diagram this is
a data engineering conference so you are
probably pretty familiar with HDFS but
it's it's the storage system that backs
Hadoop it's rock-solid everyone uses it
it's really great so why aren't we using
it well there are a couple things that
we don't really love about HDFS the
first is that it locks you into one
cluster all of the storage is only
accessible to jobs that are running in
the cluster where you put it and this
doesn't sound like a huge problem at
first blush but you'll see in a bit all
the things that we're doing because we
don't have to deal with that the second
thing is that we actually really just
wanted to store some data we didn't want
to run a bunch of servers to do it so
servers have CPU they have RAM they go
down all we really wanted was was some
bytes to get stored somewhere
and finally HDFS is a Java JVM fiefdom
if you're coming at it from languages
that aren't jvm languages you're gonna
find that it's a very very hard time to
get your data it's possible but it's not
the main use case on the other hand s3
is super flexible so the main point
about it is that once you have your data
in s3 you can actually point any number
of clusters you want at it and read it
through a file system this is crucial to
the work that we do next you can pretty
much put as much as you want in there
and there's no management at all all you
need to do is make sure that you pay
your credit card bill at the end of the
month
and the storage is gonna keep coming and
it's actually rather inexpensive
compared with the cost of running
servers to do that storage and this is
totally insane the that's the real
durability number which is 11 9s to put
that in context if you store 10,000
objects on Amazon s3 they expect to lose
one maybe every 10 million years or so
that's really really amazing the
availability is also quite good in
practice it hardly ever goes down and
finally any programming language that
you're using that's been around for more
than 10 minutes has a library for Amazon
s3 and if it's been around for 30
minutes it's probably a good library for
s3 so from go from Python whatever we're
doing it's great so you may be thinking
one of the received wisdom x' of data
engineering is that you should put your
data with your compute so that it's very
fast to do your compute this was sort of
the innovation the MapReduce paper and a
lot of other things so why would we put
our data in a networked file system and
separate it from the compute I want to
say that the received wisdom of how to
do this isn't wrong it's just that we
went a little too far with it there's a
happy balance that you can strike so
breaking the rules is actually not so
bad you know and I'll show you why this
is a snapshot of a pig job that we we
run it's a rather large job and this is
from lipstick which visualizes it so
these highlighted parts which are each
of these is a MapReduce job that pig is
written these are the only parts where
we're actually touching Amazon s3 the
first up top where we're loading the
data and the second down at the bottom
where were writing it out
everything that's happening on the
intermediate there is actually happening
in HDFS and is happening on local disk
so really the points where we hit H s3
and a given job are actually rather
small so this additional cost in
benchmarks it's roughly 2x getting to s3
vs. getting to HDFS depends quite a lot
on the instance type you use but it's
amortized over this entire long job
that's hardly ever using s3 so in
reality it's not that bad to use s3 the
flexibility that it gives you you hardly
pay for in performance so once we have
this base layer of
storage we can do some really cool
things on top of it with elastic
computing so the way this usually works
if you're coming from an on cloud
environment is that you have one
enormous cluster and pardon me here I'm
sort of mixing my metaphors a bit but
it's basically the Deathstar to rule
them all we do something very different
this is a snapshot of a host map of our
clusters from just a given time during
the day you can see that we have many
many different clusters running of
varied sizes pretty much every new
automated job that we do
launches its own cluster also every data
scientist or data engineer can have
their own cluster or multiple clusters
however many they need it's usually
about 10 to 20 at a time and node counts
are very sort of unscientific because we
run different types of nodes but you
know it's in the hundreds of nodes at
peak and it can go down to almost
nothing when nothing is running and I
did a calculation over the last last
month and roughly two hours is about the
median lifetime of the clusters we use
and so you might ask why would we do
this why would we run all of these
clusters instead of just having a single
Hadoop cluster the way many people do
there are some really good reasons for
it the first reason is that we know
exactly what's going on on any cluster
at any time so this is an example of a
job that we launched you can see up here
this is the number of yarn containers
pending that's basically the amount of
work that's that's to be done on a given
cluster you can see we launched the job
there it spikes up and then it slowly
starts going down as we we accomplish
tasks we can look at what's going on
across the rest of the cluster and see
exactly what our constraints are so for
instance on the right here that's the
disk that's in use you can see as we
start running we're slowly eating up
disk we don't have a problem while we're
doing something like exponential writing
a ton of extra disk and we're going to
have problems we can see the CPU on on
all of the hosts on our cluster this is
a heat map so the the parts that are
darkest or where most of the machines
cluster as soon as we launch the job we
hit the ceiling we don't have any more
CPU left on this cluster so obviously
this job is CPU bound adding more CPU is
going to make it run faster this is
memory over here so this isn't actually
this axis it's like a hundred and sixty
gigabytes so you can see that we're
actually really good on memory we're not
using much at all so adding memory it's
not going to help at all
now imagine if you had to do this on a
busy cluster that was running a ton of
jobs at once you'd have no idea what
your constraint was or why your job is
running slow but for us it's completely
easy because of this isolation the other
really important thing from running lots
of clusters is that our data scientists
and our data engineers and our automated
jobs don't have to wait to do their work
you can get the cluster you want and if
it's going too slow you just scale it up
to make it go faster so we can basically
optimize for the amount of time that we
want a job to take rather than for
anything else this is really important
for us because we want our employees to
be able to move as fast as they can the
next thing that doing a cluster per job
does is allows us to optimize really
nicely by picking the right hardware for
the job so for instance that job we saw
before with cpu-bound
other jobs that we have are actually
memory bound they do certain
computations that require a ton of RAM
so if you work with Amazon they sell
different types of instances instance
families and each of those optimize for
something different so the c3 instance
family at Amazon optimizes for compute
if you buy one of these instances it'll
give you proportionately more CPU and
less ram for the same price whereas if
you buy one of the r3 family of
instances you'll get more memory and
less CPU for the same price so what
we'll do is is actually pick the right
instance type for the job and in
practice you save about 30% over buying
just general hardware which is really
nice we also use m1x large a lot if you
don't care about about what's going on
if it's just a job that needs to run and
run whatever because they're dirt cheap
and Amazon has a ton of them another
super surprising thing that we do and
that we can do because we have so many
clusters writing is run a hundred
percent on spot instances almost all the
time so if you're not familiar with the
spot market in order to serve the
capacity of all their users amazon has
to have a lot of extra servers sitting
around if they're not using what they do
is make these available for purchase at
discount on the spot
market so you make a bid and you say
I'll pay this much for an instance maybe
maybe I'll pay $0.50 and if the spot
price for that instance is under that if
it's ten cents you'll get the instance
but if the spot price goes up above your
bid you'll lose it so what this means in
practice for us is two things first we
have ridiculous savings that we get by
using using this market and second our
clusters can disappear at any moment so
a little bit more detail about how we do
this so we suck all of the data about
the spot market into data dog and we use
that for visualization what you're
seeing here is a visualization of the
spot price for c-32 x-large instances in
the US east one region each of these
little lines is an availability zone in
that region and the current price at
that time so you can see that the price
is roughly around ten cents which is
what you pay per hour we start by
bidding the on-demand price which is the
the little line you see there between
the green and red which is 42 cents so
here we would be good in any
availability zone we'd get capacity and
instead of paying the 42 cents we would
pay just ten cents but sometimes things
get a little hairy and you have to fall
back to on demand if the prices go high
so we automatically do that if we're
having trouble getting spot capacity or
our clusters will fall back to on demand
and because of this you pretty much have
to monitor everything you're doing all
of your jobs all of your clusters in the
spot market as well but the upshot is
you can save eighty percent over the
on-demand price if you do that which is
an enormous enormous savings if you
couple that with optimizing for hardware
it's truly truly amazing it sort of gets
you back down into the realm of bare
metal pricing and opens up a lot of new
use cases that you can do a little bit
more about monitoring the spot price
this is an example of the opposite the
opposite behavior that we saw in the
last graph where all of the availability
zones are really really highly priced
and are above the our bid when this
happens we're not only going to lose our
clusters that are running we're also
going to be unable to get new capacity
so we would automatically switch to
on-demand but here there's an
optimization whenever we see that all of
the markets are above price will
actually page an on-call engineer and
all of our most important jobs are tuned
to be able to work on two different
types of hardware class so we can switch
out of this market which is volatile and
not very conducive to savings and switch
to a secondary instance type where we
can get better prices this is a pretty
nice way to deal with sort of short
bursts of spikes across an instance type
so this may all sound crazy but it works
really well so in practice you don't
have to wait for a cluster anymore
you wait maybe five ten minutes if you
need to launch one and then it's yours
to do what you need and when you're done
with it you can just shut it down
there's no waste from from hardware
sitting around and the the difference in
price from the spot market opens up all
sorts of new use cases that we can do on
clusters because they're so much cheaper
but it doesn't all come from free
there's stuff that we have to deal with
and most of that is around the fact that
we have many things now and they go poof
so that's brings me to the third section
of the talk which is the copious tooling
that we have to put around the edges to
actually make this work so first off we
have a hub where we're sort of
collecting all this tooling which is a
big data platform as-a-service
that our internal users can access this
is called mortar and it does a lot of
things jobs clusters schedules users
what-have-you I'm gonna focus mostly on
the ones that deal with elasticity since
I don't have time to discuss everything
but so the way a user a data dog would
work with this is they have two
interfaces one is a command line tool
and one is a website the command line
tool lets them check out their code
locally do development there and then
when they're ready to run it or test it
on a cluster they could say please run
this spark job in this environment with
all of these parameters or run this
Luigi job what have you
you'll package up the code send it in
and start it running and then on the
website they get to see all the logs
visualizations links to the clusters
pretty much everything that's going on
in real time so the architecture of this
builds on what I showed earlier where we
have our data stored in Amazon s3 on top
of that we layer elastic MapReduce which
is Amazon's Hadoop and spark as a
service product elastic MapReduce is
giving us a lot of
nice things out of the box so it
launches clusters for us it stops
clusters when we're done with them it
provisions software under them it makes
it really easy to add nodes and take
them away and it also deals with the
spot market so you can do spot pricing
and they'll take care of that one more
subtle thing that you might not realize
about elastic MapReduce if you haven't
worked with it before is that it has a
highly superior file system for
accessing files from Amazon s3 to what's
available in open source so it's much
more reliable it's much faster and this
is a big benefit of using EMR there's
some work underway to work on the s3 a
file system to make it better but right
now EMR has the best on top of that we
layer a sort of worker layer that are
responsible for the the main programs we
run
so there are Pig workers they actually
do quite a bit there running the Pig job
interacting with the cluster and making
sure that things are good
sending logs back to us where we can see
them see them in our interface and then
spark workers which actually do a lot
less so in spark we just compile the
code we send it into the cluster into
yarn and we run it there with with spark
own yarn in in cluster mode so it's
actually executing inside the cluster
for Luigi that's actually doing all of
our sort of tasks and workflow
management and those are running all the
time to make sure that things are doing
what they're supposed to up a layer from
that we have to store a lot of data
about what's actually going on in the
system so that we can query it very
quickly there's a metadata DB that's got
like all the clusters all the jobs what
their current state is also a queuing
system because we have lots of long
running things here where we want to put
jobs to our workers and have them do it
and then as many logs as we can collect
on top of that the website and the API
and then finally the CLI and the clients
they're accessing it and then a job
scheduler which is sort of it's like a
human using the the system but on a more
predictable schedule and finally we're
sending monitoring data for all of this
into data dogs so we can see what's
going on so some questions that we like
to think about an answer with this
tooling the first tricky question is we
have all these clusters they're coming
up and down how do we actually find the
right one and how do we deal with them
disappearing
our answer for that is tagging our
clusters so each of our clusters gets a
tag which tells you what it's doing so
for instance this cluster might be the
mono report cluster it's tagged with
that the other one may be something
that's doing anomaly detection and so
what we can do with that is whenever we
go to launch a job we we ask the
platform to run it on the monitor report
cluster and what the platform will do is
go find this cluster if exists and run
the job there but if not it'll start it
up and get it ready and this is really
good for dealing with spot instance
failures because it means that if the
cluster has gone down because the spot
instances we reaped or something like
that
it'll just restart it and it'll be right
back where you need it so all you have
to think about as a user who wants to
work with a cluster is what do I want to
call it and is anyone else using that
name so another thing that we have to
think about is how do we actually
monitor all this stuff how do we deal
with the fact that these clusters
disappear and this flows pretty
naturally from from the cluster tagging
idea what we do is when we tag all of
our clusters those tags go into elastic
MapReduce and they also sync over to
Amazon ec2 once we have that our
monitoring tool data dog can pull all of
those tags in and put them on all of the
metrics so what that means is a for
instance this is a this is a cluster
monitoring dashboard this is showing us
the number of CPUs that are actually in
use at any time on the cluster I've
tuned it to be the anomaly detection
cluster this little burst of activity
could be on one set of hardware we could
have lost the cluster at this point and
had to bring up a new one a new spot
instance cluster but we'll see it was
continuity here because they were both
tagged the same thing and we can choose
that tag from up in a drop-down and say
please show me everything for it
regardless of what hardware it was on
this is also super useful for monitoring
because it turns out that some of the
clusters we have we don't care if
something bad happens to them they're
just development clusters but others are
very very important production clusters
and we can set our monitors to be
focused just on the tag that we want so
for instance this monitor is saying that
the anomaly detection cluster shouldn't
run out of disk so we're launching all
these clusters how do we actually avoid
being overwhelmed by all of them just
growing growing amount of clusters well
we have several different ideas for how
to deal with this
the first one is the simplest one it's
just if you're gonna run a job have it
shut off automatically when you're done
in practice this doesn't work as well as
you'd like if you're a human working
with the cluster you're doing things
iteratively lots of things fail even
automated jobs sometimes fail and
retries would make them work so what we
do more often is the idea of a
persisting cluster we have a monitor
that's watching for whether there's any
any work happening on the cluster at any
point and will automatically shut it off
after it's been idle for a certain
amount of minutes this is really good if
you're doing some work and you want to
leave it running while you go home we'll
just automatically shut it off for you
and finally there's the old fashioned
permanent cluster where no one's going
to shut it off for you and these we keep
ourselves safe by alerting on whether
they're up for over 24 hours a really
big challenge then with many many
clusters running is how do you actually
debug problems when you have them and
the clusters go on so there are a couple
different things that we do the most
important and so the base layer of this
is sending all your logs off of the
cluster to s3e Marv we'll give you some
of this for free HDFS and yarn it'll
take care of for any of the other things
that you're working with pigs bark
Luigi's on here too you have to get all
the application logs yourself and make
sure that they are they arrive where you
need them but this is super essential
because nothing is going to be around in
the morning when you go to look for it
logs are nice but sometimes it's very
difficult in a distributed system to
piece together exactly what happened so
we have some visualizations that we run
on top of that that help lip stick shows
us exactly what happened in any job it
keeps all the counters it's sort of the
visualization that I showed earlier the
spark history server is a good version
of this for spark you can actually
submit all of your data there we don't
have that up and running yet we're
actually working on that now and then we
have a task flow visualization for Luigi
which shows us which tasks ran when and
which ones failed so that helps you sort
of orient yourself into the logs so
you're not just surfing through text and
finally it's very very important to
preserve your monitoring data
historically when you have machines that
are going up and down all the time you
need to be able to look back
like say I want just the anomaly
detection cluster and I want to see what
it was doing for the last week even when
that hardware is going something else
that's really important is you need to
make your job layer actually able to
handle failure for us the answer for
that is Luigi Luigi is a workflow tool
that Spotify open-sourced a little bit
ago it's quite nice for this the thing
that Luigi does is allow you to take a
very long complicated pipeline of tasks
that you want to do and split them up
into small individual tasks each of
those have a very simple semantics for
how to make the tasks clean up after
itself if it fails and how to make sure
that it can restart well also each task
knows how to detect whether it's already
run and not do anything if that's
happened so this is a very simple
example just two tasks in a pipeline a
and B imagine that we have tasks a and
then B depends on it
so if we run our pipeline and task a
succeeds it's good but imagine that task
B is running and the cluster that's
running on gets reclaimed for spot
instances so the task fails what Luigi's
gonna do is actually clean up all of the
partial data that may have been written
by that task and then we can just rerun
the pipeline from the start with no
additional parameters and it's gonna
launch the cluster run it again and the
job will succeed this is really nice
because it means that no human has to
get involved when there's a failure the
property that does this is called
idempotence and it just means that you
can just rerun jobs until they succeed
or until you timeout so in practice what
this does is make small failures that
happen all the time and our pipelines
not have to elevate to the level of a
human unless they're not resolving
themselves so to recap we talked about
the three different layers that we have
in the platform the the cloud storage
where we keep all of our data in a way
that's flexible doesn't require a lot of
management and lets us point mini
clusters at it the Elastic Compute where
we're running mini clusters throughout
the day using spot instances to make
them very cheap and allowing our data
scientists and engineers as much
capacity as they need and finally the
tooling layer around the edges which
helps us deal with this level of
dynamism and
be able to manage it so if you're just
thinking about how to do your own cloud
Big Data Platform or you have one that
you want to sort of move forward
have a couple recommendations for what
you might look into if you can and
you're in the cloud you should
definitely use s3 for your permanent
data and not HDFS this is actually
applicable to many other clouds as well
cloud storage is becoming a fairly
commoditize so Azure and Google cloud
have very good options for this as well
if you're in Amazon
don't start building for me from ec2
start from elastic MapReduce if you can
it's going to give you a lot out of the
box and eventually if you need to
rebuild those things you can but it's a
great place to start even better if if
you can look into using one of the
platform as-a-service that are available
Netflix has an open source one called
genie they're doing quite a bit of work
on this to move it from v2 to v3 right
now but Cubo and data breaks also have
very solid platforms data bricks is much
more focused on spark and Cube always is
pretty wide-ranging we found that
tagging is actually a really really good
way to make sure that all of these
things that you'll use to go up and down
or able to be tracked across time and
that your users don't have to think too
hard about which hardware that they need
to work on and finally make sure that
you get a workflow tool that has failure
baked in Luigi is a really good one for
this airflow is also really nice either
of those are going to work very well for
you so that's my talk thanks a lot
and if you like me are very excited
about these things and want to work on
spark and Hadoop and Kafka and all this
stuff with us hit me up on Twitter or
send me an email or hit our jobs board
we're always hiring thank you
[Applause]